What I want to do now is look at some of the different kinds of testing that exist,
and so what this really is is a very, very brief survey.
It's not intended to be exhaustive, and it's not intended
to give you an orthogonal set of kinds of testing because
there's going to be a bunch of overlap between these different categories.
What kind of testing you often hear about is white box testing,
and what white box testing refers to is the fact that
the tester is using detailed knowledge about the internals of the system
in order to construct better test cases.
And in the next unit we're going to really look at white box testing in quite a bit of detail.
The complement to white box testing is black box testing,
and black box testing refers to the fact that we're not using
detailed knowledge of the system's internals.
We're rather testing the system based on what we know about how
it's supposed to respond to our test cases.